before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
and this is why I can't forgive the
entire thing
thank you
yeah flux has ended and ends with the
vanquishers which
I'm actually not entirely sure why it's
called that ah
whatever so to explain my opening bit
um as with any serialized story
ultimately whether or not it feels worth
it by the time you get to the end
you have to stick the landing no matter
whatever else you have to stick the
landing and get the final the thing that
it was all leading to needs to at least
not be bad if not great ideally great I
mean it's why Game of Thrones went from
the thing at the center of everybody's
mind to
a show we all watched for a little bit
because it ended so bad and it was
serialized so everything was building
two
that terrible ending
is this as bad as the last season of
Game of Thrones no uh actually it's it's
not
um however
it does have a similar impact on flux as
a overall thing because the thing is I
remember when this aired
and I remember up until the Airing of
this episode
there was a decent number of people
every time I'd I'd point something out
that wasn't working for me they'd go
like well you can't judge it yet we
haven't reached the end then we got to
the end and while like there are some
people who legitimately like it
including the end that's fine you're not
wrong
um but I will say I heard a lot uh for
all the people that I heard say you
can't judge until we get to the end uh I
don't recall getting too many comments
of C it got there in the end
because for me at least
boy
it uh it really didn't
so
where do we start with this thing
honestly this is you know what
I'll do chimnal a minor favor
um I dislike this
for the same reason that I just same
core fundamental reason that I dislike
uh the Big Bang
the uh Moffat finale a finale of uh
series five now this is what I mean by
doing chip and all favor I'm pointing
out he's not the only one who makes
these kinds of mistakes so like
while I'm not a fan of chimnal's run
like it's not like nobody else screwed
up now I know not as many people are on
board with not liking uh Big Bang A lot
of people do I don't I like pandorica
opens I don't like big bang and the
reason I don't like big bang is because
it doesn't feel like it's telling a
story it feels like it is doing nothing
but tying up all of the story threads
that the previous episode and you know
the overarching story of that series had
laid out it doesn't feel like it
actually has a narrative of its own it's
just all about tying everything up and I
know that feels like well isn't that
what something should do yeah but it
should also like have its own narrative
if if you don't have a strong central
core narrative to thread the tying up of
all these other things through
then you don't engage me very well
and this is that
more so like it's kind of funny this has
the whole plot point of the doctor
getting split into three and Scattered
across time and like she's aware that it
happened and is kind of in control of
all three like simultaneously and I
really can't help but feel like that was
done because it was the only logistical
way of tying up all these stories like
we literally need three versions of our
hero to be able to wrap all this up in
the one episode we have left that hadn't
even said it's not an uninteresting idea
it's kind of nifty there isn't a lot
done with it which is why it feels to me
ultimately like such a logistical Choice
it's so much of just a uh there's no
other way we're gonna we're gonna have
the time to have her resolve everything
we literally need to have three versions
of her
so
that is what it feels like but it's
still kind of fun
unfortunately despite literally dividing
and conquering with Jody Whitaker's
doctor she's still stuck mostly with
exposition
and you know what I wonder if that would
be less frustrating if she didn't have
at least one scene that's genuinely good
and isn't just her either delivering or
prompting someone else to deliver
Exposition and that is the scene where
she's being tortured by the grand
serpent
there's still Exposition going on in
that scene
but there's also banter she's winding
him up there's a lot more just
personality that she gets to inject and
I'm not saying that like oh she had no
personality in the dark no she had it
it's just so often she was stuck
delivering technobabble or Exposition
and didn't get a chance to fully bring
the depths of her version of the doctor
across and I get glimpses of it in
scenes like this
oh
I'm all right did you look really close
it's it's fun it's great I feel like
it's one of the best single scene
glimpses into her as a character and
it's coming
in the last episode of her last proper
series
so
it just it just
it's one of those things where
the times when
this Arrow works
almost makes how much of it doesn't hurt
more because it didn't have to be like
this
there are moments that show me what it
could have been
but
anyway there are still some nice touches
little things here and there like when
um Yaz and the other companions are
reunited with the duck well one of the
three doctors that's running around at
that point
um the doctor medley hugs Diaz and
actually I think she's the only one she
hugs and Yaz kind of has this very this
big pause moment of holding her and it's
you know now accepting you know I'm
still not a shipper I still don't really
much care for the story that they did
with that especially given they did so
little with it as with so much in this
era but like as a moment leading into
things that are going to happen later
with Yaz
it's a nice moment it's sweet it stands
out more on a re-watch I like it Jericho
continues to rule continues to be
absolutely awesome and I figured out
part of what I like so much about him
he's got Hobbit energy
because when he delivers lines like this
I saw and Professor eustacious Jericho
scourge of Scoundrels and the fact that
this is his last line
that's big Hobbit energy to me and I I
love it I really love him as a character
I would have loved to have seen him as
like a companion proper
not necessarily for this doctor I mean
maybe for this doctor they only say to
say the only reason I'm hesitant on that
is because I continue to argue that the
doctor really should have been with just
Yaz to like properly develop that a
relationship you know at the Forefront
but whatever like him being a companion
with this doctor or later Dr any doctor
would have been great
he's wonderful I love him
and there's other little bits here and
there that kind of work
but
most of it doesn't
mostly for lack of investment because as
I said there isn't really a strong
central narrative to this it's just
trying to wrap everything up and even
though it literally spread split Spritz
splits its hero into three pieces and
sends her all across time and space to
be able to tie everything up in time
there's still stuff that this episode
seems to flat out forget
so
um
die inside the passenger form so vendor
runs into her in there
okay and she's trying to help him escape
and vendor asks the pertinent question
if everyone else in here was gone why
are you still here
and this was dye's answer
to them I'm insignificant no
no that's wrong that makes no sense
they went out of their way to get her
everyone else they ever captured into
the passenger form were just whoever
they managed to get to come to them you
know whether it be vendor trying to
sneak up on them and they capture them
that way or just people who thought that
the passenger form as a savior they're
not hunting people down they hunted her
down they went to they went to Earth to
find and capture her
why
why did they do that
and the fact
we get an answer to why she's still
alive in there which is that she's too
unimportant but that makes the question
of why they took her just
just inexplicable I
it's like chimno forgot that they
targeted her he forgot that they that he
wrote that they did that
and I don't know if he actually did
forget but wow does it feel like it you
want to know the other thing you forgot
he forgot that in the previous episode
he'd established that a whole big chunk
of the universe was already destroyed by
the flux
part of the universe is this all of it
no
there's nowhere near enough of it and
that does not get addressed in here at
all
like I did my best to pay as close
attention as I could
to see because
they even lay out something that feels
like maybe it's got It's meant to cover
for this because swarmint is your have
this whole thing where like their plan
is to have the flux come in at a focal
point but then go back and recreate
everything and just so they can destroy
it again and I remember thinking okay
right so that so that's how we get the
rest of the universe backing you around
except their plan never gets to that
point the final flux destroys we stop it
wind it back and watch it again
at the game they say they're going to do
that but they don't get that far
nothing gets recreated nothing gets
fixed nothing gets brought back
but it's also never acknowledged how
much of the universe is just
gone
huge massive swaths of it
and the show just forgot
I have to I have to honestly believe
that Chipmunks just forgot
that he did that
because it's not brought up here
it's not brought up in the specials
I don't expect it to be brought up in
rtd's stuff
chimney just forgot
which given how casual and callous he's
been with death and destruction up to
this point I guess you lose track of
two-thirds of the freaking universe
again I do understand the the time
pressures and trying to rewrite at the
last minute that this series went
through but
good grief
how do you not at least realize in the
edit that you did that and take out the
reference in the previous episode to how
much of the universe was destroyed
because like a bunch of the universes
destroyed regardless you showed us what
the flux did but he didn't give us a
full sense of the scale at the very
least you should have cut the line about
how much was destroyed because that put
it into perspective and it's like you
can't you can't just move I
ah
swarming is your continue to be decently
performed and are just there
I I honestly do not get what the hell is
going on with this embodiment of time
that takes on the aspect of swarm and
then kills them
but Azure at least seems like grateful
for this and calls it Ascension but so
far as we can tell it it just killed
them and then it takes the doctor's face
and talks to her but all it does is drop
hints of the master coming back later on
aware of the forces that pass against
you
this this doesn't wrap up the story
doesn't explain what the hell just
happened what this thing is what it
wants why really properly who swarming
Azure were
they're just dead in this embodiment of
time this entity that we've been told is
evil but it's just kind of standing
there being vaguely ominous and hinting
out at another villain
it's just there like what I
um
I do kind of like the suntaren's plans
and I like that it's made explicit that
they are being opportunistic
um because they weren't involved in the
flux happening but now that it has
they're finding a way to use it to their
advantage and wow one could make an
argument about whether or not the
dialectical December would be as stupid
as to fall into that trap I would point
out that they are desperate that so far
as they know there's no way to escape
the flux and they are offered a way to
possibly Escape it what are you gonna do
not take that chance and just get killed
by the flux either freaking way so I
don't think it's necessarily a problem
or even a diminishment of either of the
knowledge or the Cybermen that they fell
for that maybe they were played as like
being a little too surprised when it
happened but going along with it no I
buy that I buy that that's a solid
enough plan as far as a suntaren plan
goes also the grand serpent is there
other than the torture scene which again
is a good scene for the band from the
dialogue and that I enabling between him
and the doctor but other than that he's
just kind of there and he just gets
wrapped up and shoved through a door and
left on a little asteroid in the middle
of who knows where maybe it's another
broken up planet destroyed by the flux
they won't go acknowledged who the heck
even knows then of course there's the
other problem
the lupari
so we are told
not shown and I mean not shown at all
that all the lupari other than
calvinista are dead every Loop are on
those ships
airlocked out into space their bodies
now scatter the spacelands so
um
this one doesn't even seem like it's
done for cruelty purposes I've accused
uh chimnal of being casually cruel
rather frequently
when just casually killing off
characters left and right when it's not
necessary I do at least understand the
logistical reason of why this happens
which is that the centaurans need to
take over the lupari ships in order to
enact their plan uh with the dialects
and the Cybermen so there is a reason
for them to take over those ships they
would kill whoever's on there so
there is actually a plot mechanics
reason to do this
so it's not pointlessly cruel
it is really poorly done though
because both
in terms of they're being wiped out but
also their existence in the first place
the luparia are a completely
hypothetical entity
we have seen their ships but the only
one individual that we have seen that I
can remember at all was carvenista
we haven't seen the any other lupari So
when you say they're all dead first of
all
okay
that's meaningless we have not even seen
them we don't even know if they all look
like the same kind of breed of dog is
confidence or if some of them look like
more like Bulldogs or Pomeranian we
don't even know that because we've seen
literally none of them
they're all wiped out okay
and then the other thing that's really
poorly handled is the reaction
calvinista's reaction I'm gonna kill
every last song it's about as well as
you know being upset by the death of a
hypothetical millions or billions of
beings is but uh the Doctor Who has been
around
Mass amounts of death before
all that she acknowledges about all this
is I'm so sorry
twice
I'm so sorry I'm sorry for what the sun
Towers did to them
that's it
oh that ain't good
again honestly while it is
lazy and poorly handled in terms of well
like the sun tires need to take over the
ships I just had them kill everybody
like it's a simple lazy solution for
population of people we haven't seen and
he couldn't even milk just decent
melodrama out of it I can't even get as
worked up about this one as I have about
some other instances of chimno's Cruelty
because at least logistically I
understand how and why this happened
it's still bad and stupid but I do get
why it happened which is a lot more than
I can say for a lot of the other casual
cruelty that's gone on across this show
so
I'll take it I guess I don't know
that's just kind of where I'm at at the
end of the day with this thing I don't
know
I don't know what this is
flux overall
again I I will grant on this revisit
there was good that I didn't recognize
before
and knowing that I wasn't going to like
ultimately where it went allowed me to
see more good in episodes that I largely
remembered the flaws like Village of the
angels and finding just a lot of good
stuff that I'd flatly forgotten in
something like Once Upon Time
but
we get to the tail end and it's just
buried in plot Logistics
there's no emotional core
the villains are poorly established
it just doesn't pull together
it is doing too much with too little it
can't juggle all this and it just all
gets dropped in the end
quite literally
that freaking watch literally just gets
dropped down a hole
never comes back
normally I kind of like the idea of
writers like leaving threads for future
writers to pick up on but
that's this this is failing to finish
your own story this isn't leaving plot
threads for somebody else
anyways the vanquishers it's flux ending
with a
like a balloon with the last of the air
let out of it whatever your thoughts on
it or drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living even if you can't help me out
that way there's links to other things
that I do down in the description and
ultimately the like share subscribe to
those things help checking out any of my
stuff helps but what I really want you
to remember
this this is what's really important
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for nobody likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]